[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on
S hey guys how are you doing good how
are
you oh I'm a little nervous but here we
go you got this you can do it h oh thank
you uh so I read that to money make cob
and I gotta very impulsive and I
basically empty our savings to wipe out
uh our cars uh my student loans and uh a
huge chunks to the mortgage okay how
much money was
that oh man it was like over 40K over
40K so yeah the problem is I did all
this without telling my wife
oh foul and 10 yard penalty I really
hurt yeah I really hurt her feelings so
you told her now what was her reaction
to this obviously she's hurt but she she
just said she would have loved to uh be
part of the plan and and all this like
I'm usually in charge she's a stayhome
mom and uh I'm I'm in charge of the
finances and uh run that bad wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
let's hold up
um I think there's where the problem
lies there's this idea in your house
that you're in charge of the finances
and I think that's the mindset that led
you to think I read The Total Money
Makeover I got a great idea I'm going to
go into our savings and I'm going to pay
the
bills and that's what's gotten you here
and I think that starting instantly
right now you're doing a vocab rehab and
from now on the both of you are managing
the money it's our responsibility to
manage our
money can we agree on
that yes and uh so that was my question
how do I introduce her to you guys in a
very love loving and patient and kindly
way
um without coming off as a control freck
like I realized there a lot of
conviction in me now I I been showing
her like more like statements and
numbers and what our investments are for
through my employer like my 401k and
everything good and I realized that she
was
not even aware of that and he broke me
like it's like no we're we're a team
like there's no it's not my money it's
our money it's our resources we take
trips together we we invest together we
grow together like we're a family you
know do do you think that she wants to
like has has anything happened that you
feel like there's resistance like she
doesn't want to be involved or she
doesn't want to know or do you think
it's just been her her being in the role
she she thinks she's supposed to be in
and you you being in the role you think
you're supposed to be
in I I think it's on me I think it's
my my lack
of uh leadership like showing her things
and and like we don't do a budget I mean
we spend less than what I bring home and
I can see that because our savings were
growing every month but I I feel like
it's on me and uh
really um fully knowing how to include
her
yeah on on the budget or I we're not
really doing a budget but I I I want to
start doing that well I'd love to if you
think that you can get her to watch it
with you I'd love for us to give you
Financial Peace University and you guys
watch it together I'd love for you to
find an in-person class near you and for
both of you guys to go to this class
together and make it a date night like
this is what you go and do you're in
participating together you talk about it
afterwards um and have every dollar part
of that so the way our resources are set
up they're set up for you to work
together every dollar is an app that you
download on both of your phones you both
can look at it financial piece it is
very uh of course you can do it if
you're single but it I feel like there's
it's great for couples like it's got
that special piece to it so if we give
that to you s will you will you do it
together oh absolutely all right
absolutely okay so you seem very genuine
and there's genuine remorse here and I
think that is going to go the furthest
with her of saying Hey listen I screwed
up I haven't been doing a good job
leading uh this house being a good
husband and I want to get us on the same
page and I want to let you know that
your vote counts just as much as mine
yeah yeah and I'm no longer just going
to run this ship on my own and then just
let you know what I did in hindsight cuz
the heart behind it of he went and paid
off it's such a great thing wrong way
yeah I literally don't think it was
intentionally to be malice like I think
people enter into relationships with
like gender Ro ideas and a lot of guys
think hey it's my job or in some
families it's the woman who pays the
bills and it's like this is you and this
is me and this is just the way it's
always been but that changes today vocab
rehab guys this is we this has been a
theme Today George S hang on the line
we're going to gift you one year of
Financial Peace University as well as
one year of every premium let her have a
say in the budget let her share her
thoughts on how you're going to move
forward forward and that will get you
guys dreaming together and get this
marriage back on the right foot